[Music]
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding welcome back to
the jinjo in podcast this episode is
brought to you by delicious food
delivered with post mates guys right now
you can get $100 a free delivery credit
when you download the post mates app and
use code Jenna Julian it is the delivery
service app that makes delivering for
your favorite restaurants and food
establishments very easy and quick and
efficient and we use it all the time so
hit hit Jenna Julian in the in the app
as your code and you will get a hundred
hours of free delivery credit for your
first seven days also farmers dogs start
feeding your dog food that they actually
love made with whole real foods not
highly processed nonsense you want your
dog to get the best nutrition that they
can and they also absolutely love it
we've been feeding our dogs farmers dog
food for months now and they they love
they go absolutely nuts for it right now
you can get free shipping and 50% off of
your first two weeks when you go to the
farmer's dog calm slash annejulien or
click the link in our description thank
you sponsors thank you sponsors know
nice try what do you got over there
donut donut go Pat's congratulations
your team won your team too I wanted to
take a nap all day you want to take a
nap even if it's a good game though it
was it was an especially boring game but
you know even like good commercials
well the commercials were we were
blessed with maroon 5
but that Julian Edelman oh I just love
him because I'm a mom it's a very niche
impressionnant reference I guess yeah
I'd be surprised if someone gets it
actually I'm not gonna be surprised well
ok here the original quote asked me to
do it all the time she goes oh this
darío I just love this cuz I'm a mom and
then she dances like this alright it's
Lois from Family Guy it's really funny
impression it's been doing
well there's one episode where all of a
sudden Daughtry comes on he's like wrong
no man home she's like oh but then there
was another episode when wrong Ron
Gronkowski robbed girls I'm sorry I'm
like choking on my tongue he moved into
the house next door and Peter was like
Lois its Rob Gronkowski and she's like
oh I don't give a [ __ ] she's like that
Julian Edelman I'm sorry every time all
the moms love Julian Oh oh my god they
go crazy for his arms and his beard I do
too I mean I don't blame him I'm so
sorry but anyways I've just been doing
that non-stop for several days though
yeah it was definitely a weird Superbowl
I mean I'm super happy that Pat's won
and made history and it's just
incredible to watch them when so many
Super Bowls 6 in the last 18 years blows
my mind but at the same time it was kind
of a boring game that's fair and the
commercial sucked they were very
disappointing the whole thing fell under
whelming just from start to finish I
just like at the end of the game when
all the reporters and everyone's just
like swapping Tom Brady why is that
still a thing like why does that exist
when they swarm in the middle of the
field why does that exist
it's so dumb yeah I mean it exists
because it's it's just kind of the way
it's been and no one's changed it's
stupid that's [ __ ] stupid you see
like these cameramen just [ __ ]
getting gnarly with each other mm-hmm
it's wild yeah it's really we all know
like we all see what's going on you need
to all get the same [ __ ] picture I
don't get it
also that woman who's a reporter got
pretty much trapped in almost traffic
yeah she got [ __ ] up pretty bad but
she was getting upset too you know like
in her mind she's like I have a Tom
Brady exclusive right after the game
everyone get away from me yeah I mean
she wanted that if she got it too but I
was gnarly and they kept it rolling too
which was weird there's like no
commentary they were just like
everyone's hot Mike and yours watching
all these grown-ass people like fight
with each other to get weird
I've played plenty of sports games
nothing like the Super Bowl but if
anybody tried to touch me after the game
really can't wait for me well you
I'm start getting paid the big nice
culture sport yeah once you start
getting paid that's part of the job
Oh everyone just gets to touch yeah oh
yeah that's in the contract you have to
do media interviews and sometimes that
means you're touched no oh yes I
disagree if I was telling me you'd be
like everybody back up quit touching me
you would get fined I don't care you
just start like stiff for me you put in
jail oh man there's so frustrating I'm
Brady unleashes his epic stiff arm after
the game's over does that thing you do
in your kid just like this swing around
yeah that's part of what makes like I
don't know that part that's part of what
makes like a pro athlete what they are
cuz otherwise like most what a level of
patience is godlike yeah I got one for
the sixth time you're setting like
stupid records you're the best that
there ever was
there's just little people in hard suits
touching your face and your butt in your
body
yeah and squishing you you're literally
just finished can I get some water
you're literally getting verbally and
physically accosted at a 360 degree
radius without ever even get getting
this hug Giselle you're just there but
it's usually come down there she'll get
swamped too
you just don't want to subject her to
that she would get swamped she probably
did come down there though mother [ __ ]
whatever anyways anyway that's not what
the podcast is today well thank you guys
for watching that's it the worst vodkas
there were two seconds of our take on
after the Super Bowl well now we we have
some other interesting thing so I feel
like I don't
my mom does this thing right I'm not no
hate to my own mother was a blessing and
we love but she does this thing right
where every once in a while she's like
you know I was just moving stuff around
and I found all of this and you're like
you moved across the country like then
you moved to Oregon like you've moved
all over the place
you know how can you not notice just a
box of things that you move in with
you you know I feel like she sprinkles
them on me at nice little intervals at
her own when she's willing to get rid of
them dude I mean yeah well the W machine
must have had a software update and then
these files appeared exactly sent them
over to you exactly so this at
Christmastime
well she had FaceTime me and showed me
some [ __ ] hilarious artwork like
pieces there's one that says like don't
don't train your dog with a club that I
don't remember which one of us drew me
or my brother but it's literally it's
just a picture of a man like in front of
a dog and it's like don't train your dog
with what the [ __ ] is that don't train
your dog with a club we didn't have dogs
it's pretty straight forward
yes we're like kids draw weird [ __ ] men
but um kids be like yeah this says don't
train dogs with a club and it's a
picture of a husky and a man with a club
and then there's also a picture of me in
an outfit that says to mom I don't
remember if this is a Halloween costume
but I'm a tree so there's paper and a
small little animal inside of a hole in
my stomach
and my head is the tree you were Jett
you were Jenna from day one you were the
exact same as you are now from day one
always every little thing I see logo
your mom sends a picture or like these
sorts of things nothing ever surprises
me it's like the funniest thing because
you have this like indescribable thing
about Jenna really offbeat kind of
person it's like better than it's like
you created something else that's not a
beat noise I drum it's a good beautiful
unique butterfly yeah but imagine that I
think was like maybe fourth grade or
something and everyone's like a princess
or like a cop or like a firefighter for
Halloween a ninja turtle and your girl
is the [ __ ] tree hello
that's pretty hype though anyways my mom
at Christmastime brought some of my
short stories she said that I have like
I wrote so much stuff so I'm
sited to read some of that I have not
read all of those but I did read so when
I would get in trouble my mom used to
always always always make me handwrite
apology notes so like some of them were
like repeating what I had done wrong and
some of them were like you need to
apologize to me and you write it down
you go to your room you know you think
of all you did you're grounded for two
hours or whatever an hour and you write
me a heartfelt apology and if if it's
good you know I'll forgive you and then
you can be not in trouble in elearn so
I'll go to my room and I would [ __ ]
cry and be all upset and write an
apology letter and so apparently my mom
has hundreds of these just like piles of
them amazing well to her they're all to
her you're the she's the one who you
wronged well yeah lived with my mom yeah
you know so she blessed me with some of
the ones that she kept I don't know if
she kept all of them probably not but I
also that was like her thing we always
wrote handwritten thank-you notes and we
always wrote handwritten apologies and
when I read some of those at
Christmastime I just I can't believe the
level of sabotage I feel from her
keeping them in laughing or reading them
for imagine laughing like how dare you
her her doing this even not even keeping
them but her just making you write these
letters was all about laughing at you I
feel like in from the beginning she was
right yeah it's not really about an
apology she wanted a good [ __ ] joke
that day you know what I'm saying she
wanted two hours of quiet time and then
she wanted a [ __ ] good belly laugh
yeah yeah she literally wanted to be
entertained so she made you write her
anything
well like you know when I was a kid
didn't have TV in my room or like a
phone like nothing I had you know a
radio and some books more like my
journal you could draw you know yeah for
me if I had like depending how old it
was
you know maybe throw in some makeup if I
was [ __ ] bored maybe paint my nails
or like play with my ferret but like
this is about it you know these are the
extent of the things you could do in
your room so my mom grounded me I would
sit like right and
the doorway because I was technically in
my room but also could like maybe hear
like what was going on downstairs so
like if someone had the TV on so I could
hear it you know mm-hmm hated it
different times
oh man I'm grounded for two hours was
just like it was a [ __ ] eternity
again it's crazy though
just like I'm so glad that I was right
like I had slightly more at my disposal
entertainment wise when I was a kid but
I'm just so glad that I'm not a kid
right now
I say that all the time but it's like
yes not very fun yeah like all of this
is written down and someone physically
saved it but like kids now it's like
everything you've ever said is like on
the Internet
yeah that sucks like all of the awkward
in like middle school you know there's
like Twitter videos of it now and you're
just like [ __ ] good yeah I mean it's
like funny but it's at the same time I'm
like damn I'm so glad I'm not yeah
growing up in that right or like the the
kids on vine right the the little girl
that I loved the contrail uh I love you
like no matter what she ever does that
video always exists like that kind of
sucks as a child dude I was even though
it's a 10 out of 10 video and no one
should ever hold anything against her if
anything she lifts her up I hear you I
can't even imagine the amount of like
horribly cringy things I did as that age
and no one ever is gonna know about him
yeah well that's not true there's plenty
of people that remember them nobody
mm-hmm say I just don't talk to him
anymore anyways my mom gave me some of
this stuff that a lot of it I had to
write for school but I don't know I
haven't read these stories so I'm I
really want to read this these uh ooh
that graphic should we start with this
yes sir that
okay I'm gonna omit these people's last
names but let me let me stomachs let me
read uh i'll read their poems first and
then i'll read mine because i see one
that looks [ __ ] to me these are his
poems yes
all right so this says something like
spiders spotlight
so I think spiders was like our first
grade class or something or second grade
third grade I remember it was our group
and this this must have meant that we
were the best in the class so we were
getting a spotlight for our writing hmm
these look like poems about animals okay
okay this one is called mammals by
Elizabeth
Loki she was my best friend we grew up
like right by each other she's [ __ ]
the [ __ ] I'm sorry in this look great I
don't know I don't remember but this
looks like first second grade yeah a
mammal is a creature that has to breathe
air you and I are mammals we are
warm-blooded and we have hair lots of
mammals have tails five ellipses bunny
rabbits seals and whales Oh Libby [ __ ]
that one up that was good okay this is
dogs by Erin dogs dogs all around up and
down on the ground everywhere you look
there are dogs up and down all around
that's pretty good okay
this is animals by Tom animals reptiles
mammals too don't you think they have a
fun job to do they can run or jump or
sleep all day if you say a fish is a
mammal I say no way okay
spoiler alert that kid went to like an
Ivy League college so he deserves it
everything he ever scholarship great
paying job okay this is puppies by Erin
puppies puppies here and there puppies
puppies everywhere puppies puppies I
want one puppies puppies they're fun
puppy okay that was just selfish that
was all about you think of someone else
for once my guy okay and now last but
not least let's compare mine to my
classmates because I haven't read this
mammals by Jenna a mouse is a mammal and
so is a dog a frog is not a mammal it is
an advocate duckbill platypuses of
mammal to over that obscure
[ __ ] even though it lays eggs ooh a
semicolon a bat is a mammal that flies
and a mammal is you and I that's you
covered so much ground and one paw and
like I get you're like trying to like
you're playing basketball kinda trying
to cross the reader over and like break
their ankles with that bomb okay to be
fair though like everyone else's was
sort of like a poem mine has two [ __ ]
semicolons in it too a duckbill
platypuses a mammal two semicolon even
though it lays eggs semicolon so not
only are you are you hitting them with
these sick misdirections
but you're laying on this like advanced
grammatical style but they're not
correct it doesn't matter
nobody's gonna say that at this age I
just see those dudes you see the
semicolons and you're like [ __ ] [ __ ]
where did you get those semicolons why
is the bottom one longer I've never seen
okay
compare me to my other classmates though
because I feel like I had a lot of
information clearly this girl loves
science a little bit of analysis here
between you and Aaron we got other
things to read mm-hmm which Aaron the
girl Aaron of the boy Aaron wait well I
just said it was gonna omit their last
I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay well we could bleep that we'll
bleep that well actually believe that
I'm sorry I'm sorry no one heard it okay
it's bleep so Aaron the second one down
the page my problem with his poem is one
two three four five six seven eight nine
he says puppies ten times in a 5-line
poem he says it twice per line we get it
it's a good all right you know what
let's just move on I just well okay go
ahead
they're fun really puppies all right I
know that something I didn't know
duckbill platypuses a mammal - that's
informative and you're bringing
something to the table at age what
10 thank you I wasn't 5 how old are you
probably between 5 and 7 so 10 no okay
whatever
I just think yours was it was it was
different it's definitely different I
think I got highlighted because you know
I really I went off the beaten path
there also you brought it to the reader
you said just like you and I you whoever
is reading this you're involved in this
I draw you back in okay so this this
showcases what looks like my beautiful
drawing ability which I don't really
have any but I think this assignment was
to like copy a book jacket and sort of
like write about it so this is called
the great gerbil roundup I don't get it
wait I think Alton what so in the book
jacket it says Elton was whose parents
are divorced if he is with one of his
parents rarely the other one is there
Elton has blonde hair he also has a
strong personality he's a wise kid
because in the body book oh sorry Elton
was one of the only ones that knew the
roundup wouldn't work out I like this
book because it really kept me into the
book it was interesting funny and
emotional I recommend this book to
animal lovers because the gerbils have a
role in the book rol they have a role in
the book that makes you feel like
breaking down and crying until miss
wazoo saves the day this book is
extremely funny and wonderful where are
you going then on the back it says
gerbil Pennsylvania was the most unheard
of town that anybody knew until Elton
Wazzu and his father moved there mr.
wazoo was part of a company called inter
Petco mr. wazoo built a farm that bred
gerbils gerbil wanted something to put
an on the map to the town this is just a
book report I thought that was gonna be
better but if you can see this
incredible illustration I can't draw for
[ __ ] what does that on the left the key
look at this gerbil
[ __ ] I literally don't think I've gotten
any better at drawing since then either
like that looks like something I would
draw now like this this is like a cool
little style you got
it's like doodlee I don't think so no
it's cool okay I think this is a yeah
written and illustrated this is called
the yin-yang family which clearly you
know an art teacher taught me how to
take a thumbprint mm-hmm and then you
turn it into a yin-yang
oh my god that is your thumbprint okay
you listening to the story
hello I'm podcast great amazing hey said
Sam you can't do that in monopoly you
can't go to jail - go and get $200 can
top said his sister - there ying-yang
thumb prints how many times that you dip
your finger into a lot throughout this
mom said Sam amy cheated in monopoly oh
wow don't talk to me like that said his
mother you're punished oh my god
amy was laughing as hard as she could
Sam stomped up to his room and made
shouting noises he slammed his door his
room was full of ying yang of course
because they were the yin yang family
very literal interpretation suddenly he
heard crunching noises adrd
he looked out the window in some bear
tracks what what was a bear doing with
his apples
maybe next he'll eat Sam Sam rushed out
of his room to see what it was that he
[ __ ] so many oh my god there's so
many yang Yang's they're all just thumb
prints he's studied the crushed apples
and then the tracks near sorry I like
stapled the book too close to where I
wrote it so Oh
near something he had heard the faint
sound of walking okay here we go
oh he ran over to see what it was oh I
should have known said Sam it was their
next-door neighbor's dog ooh listen to
how he spelled neighbors and [ __ ] Juarez
honestly that's how it should be spelled
neighbors neighbors he had stepped on
the apples oh it was a misdirection an
inside job that night Sam apologized to
his mother why we have a theme here
don't we yeah they had spaghetti SP AG g
ET TI e you just thought hey I know
there's a lot of double letters in this
word let's just throw them all for
dinner and for dessert they had fresh
apples with cinnamon sticks Wow
tying it all together look I really
mailed it in on this ying yang member
family well no because this is the back
of them so you're not allowed to see
anything is that one more page no
honestly 10 and a 10 book report thank
you illustration thank you I love the
artwork
I love how every single like your except
the dog doesn't have you hanging he's
just a thumbprint or was there the bear
yeah no he's the dog the dog this is
good you clearly had a creative process
for this you know speaking of process
don't feed your dogs highly processed
foods guys feed your dogs farmers dog
fresh delicious food that is healthy you
just really like weight during an
Andorian process okay you can get it
right now at the farmer's dog calm
basically what it is is you go online
you fill out some information about your
pet their size their breed their eating
habits and you go through the order it's
very easy and simple and then the food
arrives in a pre in a box with
pre-portioned packages so it's very easy
to feed them basically so for instance
we have the Iggy's on the same diet so
we feed each of them like a quarter pack
I mean
and it's very easy because it's like it
comes prepackaged and you don't need to
like measure out with cups and
everything it's all ready for you
and it comes in a box with it comes cold
it's fresh and you put it right in the
freezer and then the day before you
ready to feed them you put it in the
fridge and defrost slowly and then
they're ready to eat it's like the
easiest we've gone through so many
different meals for the dogs and this is
by far the easiest and they honestly
love it the most because it's just
really delicious and good for them right
now guys you can get 50% off your two
week trial fresh healthy food at the
farmer's dog calm slash annejulien or
you click the link in the description
and let us know how your little pup or
loves it I think you'd be really happy
with the results everyone wants to do
right by their little pet so you can do
right by yours by getting the farmers
dog also guys do right by yourself when
you want something from the grocery
store or from the fast food joint down
the street or from wherever all the way
ten miles away get on post mates and
have a wonderful post mate bring it to
you quickly efficiently you get to see
where they are on the map the whole time
you can sit on your butt on the couch
you can get work done you can get post
mates deliver to your office wherever
you are throughout the day they only you
know they're all over the place all the
time so if you think you know you might
not have a chance to go out because
you're too busy doing something post
mates is there for you it's a super
convenient app and honestly we use it
all the time it is so cool that they
sponsor us because it is genuinely like
one of the most used apps and services
we do use currently even if it's
something around the house dish soap
batteries tape you can have a post mate
deliver that from whatever store has it
near you and right now post mates is
giving you $100 of free delivery credits
for your first seven days when you used
code Jimmy Julian in the post mates app
so just download the post mates out save
the hassle and get going with the
awesome delivery service that is post
mate so thank you post guys thank you
farmers dog
thank you sponsors and carrying on here
so I was just looking at this because
this is a story but this is stapled on
to a different story because this one
says ode by jenna mourey and is just a
page of
something that's different than the rest
of what it's stapled to because this
says personal experience have font yeah
but this is a different this is just one
page sorry so I'll read this one it's
called personal experience there we go
which was written in 1998 how old was I
in 1920 Thank You Julie I can't I don't
know if this is like if this is missing
a page or you know I don't it sounds
like she gave you incomplete yeah well
it's all just sort of like put together
all right
this says it has no title it just says
personal experience mhm I miss him a lot
I moaned in a high whiny voice there's
nothing we can do sweetie he's gone my
dad was trying to get me to feel better
about our cat running away he had feline
leukemia a highly dangerous cat disease
but I didn't know about his sickness I
was only four for the record this is a
true story I think this sounds like it
because our first cat Kato was a cat
that came to our lake house and we
started feeding it because we liked it
big mistake
no he's our cat yeah well he had always
sort of been like a you know a street
cat yeah but he loved us but he did I
think eventually run away because he was
sick and yeah anyways this is a real
story we'll just have to get another pet
pet daddy side because he knew I wasn't
gonna want a new pet I wanted Kato my
favorite cat why don't we just go to the
pet shop today and get a new pet my dad
pleaded ok highside I'm in the car I was
all jumpy I completely forgot about my
old cat and was happy just to get to see
other animals lollipop farm I said with
curiosity this was my very first time
there that was like it's like a big
animal rescue place basically it was
actually calling all the pop for me yeah
and then I volunteered there later when
I was in high school but it's dope it's
like awesome that's like our big shelter
I ran out the door in gas when I saw all
the doggies and kitties and
windows I galloped inside like a horse
and a parade I ran around the pet store
screaming with delight
daddy let's get this one but I always
got the same answer no no we want a baby
pet we've looked at some mean ugly dogs
that barked in depth and wolfed and made
loud moaning noises I walked over to a
small quiet dog I held out my hand so he
could sniff me but I guess his way of
greeting me was drooling all over it and
licking it back up Kermit Kermit by now
my brother had disappeared somewhere I
started to cry because you know when
you're little you're always wanting
someone to be there with you even if
they are in all capitals really dorky
like Devon I went wandering all over now
and then old ladies would say are you
lost little girl no I'm fine no finally
I thought Devon he was crouched down in
the floor but what did I care I just let
all my feelings out I was so mad at him
for leaving me by myself I said yeah
that's all pet oh that's you yelling hey
Jenna look at these cute kittens kittens
why didn't you say so you were too busy
running around telling those old ladies
you were fine and doing your Wawa we was
that I couldn't tell you I crouched down
like Devon and peered into the crate all
the kittens were female and white with
gray on their noses they were only four
weeks old I was delighted at their
playfulness I stuck my finger in the
cage and they all came over and licked
it they had rough sandpaper tongues just
then my dad walked over and said where
were you - we were kitten hunting I said
which kitty should we get daddy I said
full of excitement it's up to you and
your brother he replied I peered back in
the box just then a small black ball of
fur in the very back corner of the cage
poked his nose out from in between his
paws he was all black except for the
tips of his paws under his armpits and
on his stomach he had gorgeous green
yellow eyes that shone like glass on
Petes
his delicate white whiskers twitched he
seemed he sleepily strode over to his
and laughed of some water he stretched
himself out and yonder big yawn the pet
shop keeper told us that he was a male
he started playing with the other
kittens tails and they didn't appreciate
it much my dad was talking to the pet
shop worker
I liked that black one daddy I screeched
while I was a [ __ ] brat he wondered
what you wanted the pet shop worker
pulled the trembling kitten out the poor
thing was shaking all over the pet shop
worker handed him to Daddy
he was holding him too high for me to
see him I was just squirming with
excitement let me see him daddy
alright see you support his hindquarters
and you I know how to hold him happy the
terrified kitten was staring at me like
a nuclear warhead just broke out oh you
have an incredibly descriptive way of
writing at 12 years old
thank you meat I held him on his back
which are not supposed to do so that I
could see his face his fur was so soft
and silky I could feel his little heart
racing his little whiskers twitched
again can we get him daddy
haha sure sweetie I grinned so hard my
face ached with pain and in fact I think
I scared the kitten daddy grasped him
with his monstrous hands and gave him to
the pet shop worker they took him to his
room to this room where people that were
wearing big white jackets daddy said
they were doing something so that we
couldn't have babies I ran outside to
feed the goats while we bought the
kitten we hopped in the car and cruise
to the nearest pet store we bought food
dishes toys a bed and combs for him hi
there cutie i hummed in a singsong voice
leave him alone Jenna my dad please for
the love of God he needs to adjust to
his new house we had gotten home and I
was sticking my head into his pet
transporter cage farther than he could
stand finally he gained enough to creep
out of his cage naturally the first
thing I did was sit down and observe him
he sniffed and marked everything as time
went on we found out that he was
allergic to beef and he was lactose but
we found out but we found that out the
hard way I wanted badly to name him
Daisy oh we wound up naming him look at
this word
bonito Benzing bombolini oh my god or
Benny for short today he's an annoying
stupid lousy no-good
[Laughter]
at the very end you just go [ __ ] ham
like the last sentence I gotta say like
your writing is impressive for 12 years
old I feel like you do a good job of
telling it how it is even when you're
telling how annoying you're being in the
story and you're you're very descriptive
it's good thank you
it's a good story yeah that cat hated us
his name was Benny and he absolutely
hated it there was something that you
said that it was really funny singsong
voice I loved that I hummed in a
singsong voice all right on to the the
most embarrassing oh here we go oh this
is a letter to Santa huh I thought I had
more of these oh okay so this one God
this one clearly says in my mom's
handwriting I will not speak rudely to
my mother and then I filled up the
entire piece of paper or I will not
speak rudely to my mother Bart Simpson
style nice and since the whole thing
okay this is a letter to Santa okay
this was written in 1997 hmm so it's oh
it's in cursive mmm the most useless
skill you ever learned in school I like
cursive handwriting but it never never
became necessary to know yeah it never
really took off no point did you
actually have to like they would promise
that you would be pretty much screwed
without Kirsten yeah no point did you
ever need it again
mmm everyone signature which everyone
already knew how to do mm-hmm
god I spent so much time struggling I'm
trying to make cursive happen right
grade fourth grade teachers like back
off mm-hmm I want to write how I write
cursive just looks nasty uh so I was 11
I guess yes
dear Santa I'm so glad it's crossed out
finally spelled incorrectly finally
Christmas I know that you and your elfs
work so hard exclamation point since I
know that you will get
tired and will need your nourishment
please accept these cookies we have to
offer you I'm sorry that we did not bake
these cookies or even buy them gift to
us from the Schwab's our friends wing to
Santa be like one of our neighbors gave
us Christmas cookies so we just put them
out for Santa as well guilty conscience
made you write that in the letter you
did not have to write that's a sinner he
would never have known they were from
the Schwab's
we did have cookies but we gave them to
our neighbors the Miller what then they
give you cookies yeah we always gave our
neighbors cookies exchange cookies
always they probably read gifted some
years - Santa - probably hope so the
milk is 1% I hope you don't mind my
brother Devin said that we should give
you skim milk because you are too if you
like skim milk better there's some in
the refrigerator I have been very good
this year or at least I think so
everyone else has been good this year to
have a very very Merry Christmas love
Jenna PS if any of your reindeer get
hungry there are carrots and apples in
the fridge adorable it's really cute
very cute yeah I really am just a rat
huh well you just you want everyone to
know like what you are a part of and
what you're not a part of because if
something's going on and you you're not
playing a part in it you need them to
know about it you didn't suggest skim
milk your brother did also you just gave
him free rein to go in your fridge
beads alright alright what is this I
think this is an apology letter which I
hope that my mom can give me more of
these because these are great dear mom I
don't know when this was written but
this looks like my handwriting is much
younger than the one we just read dear
mom it was wrong of me to call you names
and you don't deserve it
you didn't do anything to me and it was
very wrong of me to be mean to you next
time if I call you a name for no good
reason
I will lose n64 for one week and I will
write you two pages of apologies I'm
sorry
huge letters I will try not to call you
names because you don't deserve it
thank you for the Pizza Hut pizza
exclamation point pizza it was very good
exclamation point what a treat for
exclamation points that that comes off a
little sarcastic no it was mister thank
you for helping me with my paper even
when I was rude to you I guess I'm just
a little tired today I was getting used
to the three-day weekend and going to
school made me grumpy oh I'm sorry
love Jenna that is so cute you're just
grumpy oh that's so cute I can't get
over thank you at the top of my mom's
handwriting it says if jenna is not
downstairs by 7:05 then she does not I
can't read that I've never been able to
really read my mom's handwriting
something let's see this says dear mom
well first of all this is written in
like five different pen colors so I
definitely had one of those clicky ones
with all the different colors and I was
really trying to make this you know if
something thought out dear mom I'm sorry
about what happened this morning and all
the mornings before it's not fair for
you to keep driving me to school when I
miss the bus I think that to solve this
problem I need more time
so at night I need to have all my school
stuff ready then in the morning I have
to be downstairs by 7:05 instead of 7:10
if I still miss the bus I will have to
walk to school if the weather is not
horrible
if you end up driving me I will stay in
my room all afternoon
I hope this plan will work sincerely
jenna mourey both cursive and printed I
like it I like that you're proposing a
solution well that was half of the
apology you can't just say I'm sorry you
did like say how you're gonna fix it
exactly so you you would take the bus
with them when you were late for it you
would just tell you well like so the bus
used to pick me up at the end of my
street so you know a couple minutes walk
or run or whatever but like you know
whether depending it would be there like
seven oh five seven oh seven but like
he's on time every day and you're just
like a minute late then you miss the bus
so I imagine it's you know after a
couple days of just being a couple
minutes late my mom's like in her bed
you know not fully ready to just like be
up I'm like mom books again and at that
point it's too far if I walk I'm gonna
be late for school so she just would be
like alright I'm gonna drive you but I'm
not happy about it you know No yeah then
that was a school bus mm-hmm I never had
a school bus how'd you go to school we
had a public bus like it's actually
called the Big Blue Bus and say yes we
took so I took that too middle in high
school mmm-hmm elementary school we
walked because we were close enough so
we walked to school my parents mainly
walked I always took the bus I took the
bus so I was like 17 yeah I never ever
had an option to do that I don't know
what it was it maybe is because our
schools are too big or something there
was no like there's no one bus route
either cuz there was like such a big
area yeah but no that's that's right
once my brother got his license then he
would drive me sometimes but he was
always too busy doing like cool kid [ __ ]
ever like drive me places like you know
outside of driving you to school
or just like well sometimes yeah he
would drive me to school in the
morning but like I played sports or like
we did different stuff after schools
yeah we it was I had to like walk home
or take the bus
yeah or have a quarter to call my mom to
come get me yeah I feel like that was
the that was the good and the bad thing
about having older siblings is like both
of my older brother and my older sister
had cars way before I did so I would be
able to have rides pretty often in high
school and stuff but then I also had to
take the bus quite a bit yeah well once
my brother went to school then I was
allowed to use the car then I had a car
yeah so I do want to mention I don't
have anything on hand like this but I
know for a fact that somewhere in some
closet my mom has like books and books
of my summer journals maybe keep summer
journals when I was a kid so it was
basically to me make me not [ __ ] off and
do whatever I want on the side I was
like I had some sort of I have those too
yeah so every day bad though I haven't
read mine I don't even know what mine
are like oh it can be a doozy sometimes
well like some of its really cute and
some of it you're just like man yes
sucks well I'm gonna dig those up and do
my best to find as many of them as I can
and also maybe even some book reports
because I think some of my schoolwork
was pretty funny oh and then I can do my
version of this on another podcast yeah
and mom if you have any more apology
notes bring them they're pretty made we
need more we need more just
documentation of young Jenna it is too
funny or if you're a parent and you're
looking for something hilarious to keep
forever it's an apology note that's so
it worked though it always worked I want
to see the other apology notes something
about you apologizing your mom as a
child is just so cool some of them are
like really specific yeah you know yeah
cuz I'm just like a little [ __ ]
yeah but whatever yeah the repeating one
is nice too that that might be frame
worthy I will not speak to my mother is
so funny yeah wonderful well thank you
for sharing this this little piece of
your childhood with us was really cute
it really was thank you me
it's really funny he's funny to look at
although I did like the top of the
podcast this these poems here oh yeah
yeah yours was the best by far no no no
I'm absolutely not biased at all in fact
I think I was rooting for Aaron a little
more but your poem just stood out to me
yeah thank you for sharing and again I
have a distinct memory of my summer
journal being the bane of my existence
um I want to say like between like the
end of elementary school although middle
school may be a little tough so we like
your mom told you you had a journal
every day would you like check and make
sure thee she's read it well no she I
mean I don't know if she read it but she
may I would like make sure that I showed
her a full page what had to be one whole
pays out of my journal but aren't you
glad you have them now
well yeah I can't wait to see them cuz I
only I can only imagine what the [ __ ] I
was writing about hmm like myspace or
like an iPod or some crazy [ __ ] that was
going on in my little kid life mm-hmm so
I will do my best to get my hands on
those and bring them to you so we can
explore them together I think I'll be
fine yeah I'm ready this is really I
didn't think I'd cry but I said it to
you yeah go ahead and read my tweets
that'll be fun well thank you guys for
hanging out for another podcast with us
we will see you next week on the podcast
we'll see you all week on stream and one
quick little announcement is we have
recently relaunched our gaming youtube
channel not for anything like original
playthrough content because all of our
gaming content happens on Twitch but we
are actively going to be posting clips
moments highlights and just videos that
are from our twitch streams on the
YouTube channel yeah so you know a lot
of you aren't awake yeah twitch streams
can be really tough for a lot of you to
make yeah also tune in for 6 hours at a
time and even if you make it if you want
to go back and watch it which is really
hard for you to do that so we're gonna
the the link is youtube.com slash
Julian games will Lincoln in the
description and will probably link it in
the description from now on it might
actually already be there but just just
so you guys know you will have some
twitch content outside of just twitch
now which we're excited about
but anyway you guys are wonderful week
be good and we'll see you later
[Music]